- Hello, I'm Ewan McGregor
and I play Christopher Robin.
And today I'm taking the BuzzFeed quiz
Which Winnie The Pooh Character Are You?
So, the first question is how
do you like to eat your honey?
Straight out of the jar, on your toast,
on your pizza, on your pancakes,
on your fruit, in your tea.
I would take it straight out of the jar.
How would your best friend describe you?
Ambitious, optimistic, introverted,
loving, hilarious, adventurous.
I think probably adventurous.
- Oh, that would be telling.
I wouldn't be so indiscreet as to say.
Choose a Disney princess to
join you on an adventure.
For the sake of my daughters,
it's gonna have to be Elsa.
How do you like to spend your free time?
Cooking, exercising, hanging
out with friends and family,
watching TV, traveling, sleeping.
Oh, the truth is there's
a quite of few of those.
There's sleeping, traveling,
and hanging out with friends and family.
So I'm gonna have to
choose between those three.
I'm gonna choose hanging
out with friends and family.
And then describe your laugh in one word.
Deep, infectious, loud, soft,
rambunctious, or maniacal.
I would like to hope it was infectious.
(drum rolling)
You got Winnie-the-Pooh.
Hey!
Oh, hunny, you're a
highly curious individual
who is equal parts lovable and charming.
You're a thoughtful person who knows
exactly how to turn someone's day
from dreadful to wonderful.
Friends stick to you like honey
because there's no one else
quite like you, Winnie-the-Pooh!
Oh, I'm delighted I got
Winnie, 'cause he's my man.
I think they got it absolutely right.
(laughs)
I would hope so.
(light music)
(creaking)